waffenruhe für nordsyrien trotz der
einigung zwischen den usa und der türkei
wird immer noch gekämpft
rückenwind für csu chef der parteitag
bestätigt markus söder mit 91,3 prozent
im amt
[Applaus]
generalstreik und demos in barcelona die
separatisten legen die stadt lahm und
auch weite teile kataloniens
[Applaus]
die nachrichten des tages heute mit
barbara hahlweg guten abend und
willkommen zum nachrichtenüberblick an
diesem freitag norbert könig ist auch
dabei für den sport schwimmen
wenig hoffnung macht die von den usa mit
der türkei ausgehandelte waffenruhe für
nordsyrien in den kurdengebieten stärken
trotzdem bei kämpfen weiter menschen
eu-ratspräsident tusk sagt das sei in
wirklichkeit keinen waffenstillstand
sondern die aufforderung an die kurden
zu kapitulieren
vereinbart ist folgendes fünf tage lang
soll eine waffenruhe gelten in dieser
zeit sollen sich alle kurdischen kämpfer
aus einer sogenannten sicherheitszone
entlang der grenze zurückziehen
allerdings ist nicht genau festgelegt
wie groß diese zone ist die türkei sieht
sie entlang des gesamten kurdengebiet
die kurden reden nur von einem kleinen
abschnitt glück weit wort berichtet in
rastern ein wurde heute ungeachtet der
vereinbarten waffenruhe weiter gekämpft
nach syrischen angaben kamen dabei auch
sieben zivilisten ums leben es gab 20
verletzte us-präsident tram hat die
vereinbarung von ankara gestern gelobt
er sei zwar einige tage böse gekämpft
worden aber kein amerikanisches blut
geflossen so trump im wahlkampf in texas
das sei wie bei kindern erst lassen wann
sie etwas kämpfen dann zieht man sie
wieder auseinander
die weite und aus welchen städten sich
die kurdischen milizen von der grenze
zurückziehen sollen darüber enthält die
vereinbarung keine angaben für die
türkei ist die offensive aber
keinesfalls beendet
ankara verlegt weiter truppen an die
grenze auch sonderpolizei einheiten die
die verwaltung der eroberten gebiete
aufbauen sollen die frage der
sicherheitszone wird sich klären wenn
die usa bis dienstag ihr versprechen
einhalten geschieht das nicht werden wir
unsere militär operation noch intensiver
vorfinden die amerikaner interpretieren
das abkommen offenbar ganz anders
innerhalb von fünf tagen ziehen sich die
kurdischen kräfte aus den gebieten
zurück wo die türken jetzt
stehen nach dem rückzug stoppt die
türkei alle militäroperationen in
nordost syrien
[Musik]
ähnlich äußerten sich auch die kurdisch
geführten syrisch demokratischen kräfte
in einer im internet verbreiteten
erklärung heißt es man werde sich nur
aus dem gebiet zwischen therapeut und
russell 1 zurückziehen
der türkisch kurdische konflikt hat
längst auch deutschland erreicht so
demonstrierten in den vergangenen tagen
zahlreiche kurden gegen die türkische
militär offensive und das nicht immer
friedlich in herne etwa beschädigten
demonstranten ein türkisches café
mehrere menschen wurden verletzt auch in
den türkischen moscheen hierzulande
spielt der konflikt eine große rolle
susanna santina nach hinweisen dass
deutschlandweit in die tib moscheen für
präsident erdogan streak gebetet wird
drehen wir versteckt in bad vilbel und
finden heraus der imam spricht von den
schlachten der türkischen armee und
verherrlicht den märtyrertod
jeder muslim sollte beten herr mögliche
mir das märtyrertum wenn die zeit für
ihre menschen gekommen ist und sie sich
dem krieg verweigern ist das keine
schande mein bruder
die ditib moscheen im dienste türkischen
regierung wie schon bei dem angriff auf
frieden als solche videos verbreitet
wurden
die armee die einmarschiert ist die
armee des propheten mohammed die tipp
wollte uns kein interview geben
auch unsere fragen an den zuständigen
bundesinnenminister blieben
unbeantwortet
die nach deutschland trägt und auch
predigt auch finanziell und das hat
natürlich dafür gesorgt dass politik
einen sehr großen resonanzraum hier
bekommen hat der einfluss der türkischen
regierung zeigt sich auch besonders in
den sozialen netzwerken wo vielen videos
den krieg unterstützen und kritiker mit
hass post zuschicken oft anonym
es gibt rund 6000 rolle wie durch das
erdogan regime finanziert werden
unterstützt werden die nichts anderes
machen als kriegspropaganda in den
sozialen netzwerken zu verbreiten die
von uns in bad vilbel aufgenommene rede
des imam wurde übrigens vor dem
offiziellen freitagsgebet verbracht
im internet veröffentlicht die tib nur
ein teil der freitagspredigt ohne
kriegspropaganda wechselt mit diehl oder
ohne morgen ist wohl die stunde der
wahrheit im britischen unterhaus bekommt
prompt johnson eine mehrheit für sein
abkommen das er gestern mit der eu
ausgehandelt hat er sieht so aus als ob
wohl nur eine handvoll stimmen
entscheidend sein könnten
am frühen abend rief johnson sein
kabinett in downing street number ten
um es auf den neuesten stand zu bringen
diana zimmermann in london geht es
morgen aus hat boris johnson
mittlerweile mehr abgeordnete auf seine
seite ziehen können
hier wird natürlich fieberhaft gezählt
abgeordnete und ein äußerungen der
wackelkandidaten gelauscht bei uns sonst
gibt sich wie wir das von ihm kennen
siegesgewiss aber er braucht morgen 320
stimmen und momentan hat er nur 300
sicher die praxis ideologen in seiner
partei scheinen den din einiges
abgewinnen zu können aber auch sie
treffen sich erst morgen früh um zu
entscheiden ob sie nun dafür stimmen
oder nicht der wein hat die regierung
versucht oppositionelle stimmen zu
gewinnen indem sie labour abgeordneten
einen schutz von arbeitnehmerrechten
versprochen hat trotzdem glauben die
meisten beobachter hier das sonsten
morgen zwei bis drei stimmen fehlen
werden das kann natürlich ganz genauso
gut anders herum ausgehen und deswegen
können wir uns nur sicher sein dass die
briten ist auch morgen wieder spannend
machen
dankeschön nach london diana zimmermann
und auch das ist ein ergebnis vom
zweiten gipfeltag in brüssel albanien
und nord mazedonien müssen weiter aufs
beitrittsgespräche mit der europäischen
union warten
frankreich die niederlande und dänemark
hatten bedenken eine solche entscheidung
muss aber einstimmig fallen
die balkan länder reagierten enttäuscht
kommissionspräsident juncker sprach von
einem schweren historischen fehler kaum
einer kennt sie aber fast jeder zahlt
sie die grundsteuer betrifft eigentümer
genauso wie mieter weil sie auf völlig
veralteten zahlen basiert musste eine
reform her
und der hat der bundestag heute
zugestimmt künftig sieht es so aus der
wert des bodens und die durchschnitt
etliche miete sollen berücksichtigt
werden aber die bundesländer können auch
eigene modelle entwerfen
am ende entscheiden die kommunen wie
hoch die steuer genau ausfällt und eine
weitere entscheidung des bundestags das
wohngeld für geringverdiener wird ab
kommendem jahr erhöht um
durchschnittlich 30 prozent von der
leistung sollen dann geschätzt 600
60.000 haushalte profitieren deutlich
mehr als jetzt
übermorgen das flugzeug nehmen das
könnte für manche knifflig werden zwar
hat die gewerkschaft der flugbegleiter
ufo ihren angekündigten warnstreik bei
der lufthansa abgesagt aber stattdessen
will sie jetzt die lufthansa töchter
euro in german wings lufthansa cityline
und sunexpress bestreiten
es drohen über 300 flugausfälle der
anschlag von halle mit zwei toten war
für viele ein tragischer weckruf eine
synagoge hatte der täter mitte letzter
woche stürmen wollen und nur die massive
tür verhinderte ein noch größeres
blutbad
jetzt also die frage was tun zum schutz
der juden in deutschland überhaupt zum
schutz vor militanten rechtsextremisten
die innenminister gaben heute antwort
patricia wiedemeier
jüdische einrichtungen sie sollen
künftig besser geschützt werden durch
mehr polizei vor ort aber auch durch
technische und bauliche maßnahmen dies
ist nur einer von zehn punkten auf die
sich die innenminister geeinigt haben
ungewohnt schnell ohne große
kontroversen seien nun taten den worten
gefolgt es war ein glanzpunkt der
demokraten in diesem lande heute
nachmittag
vereinbart wurde eine verstärkte
zusammenarbeit der behörden zum beispiel
von bka und verfassungsschutz ein verbot
von extremistischen vereinen und
veranstaltungen anbieter von internet
plattformen müssen strafrechtliche
relevante inhalte melden und löschen und
eine verschärfung des waffenrechts
wir müssen schon konsequenzen ziehen aus
dem was wir wissen nämlich dass die
rechtsextremistische szene
außerordentlich gewaltbereit und wochen
finden ist
zudem sollen kommunalpolitiker die
besonders häufig hass und häme im netz
ausgesetzt sind künftig besser geschützt
werden wir wissen auch dass die
demokratie von unten sterben wird wenn
ich dafür sorge tragen dass
kommunalpolitiker sind und politiker den
schutz bekommen den sie brauchen
kritik kam prompt von der fdp sie lehnt
die geplante verschärfung des
waffenrechts ab ein generalverdacht für
alle legalen waffen besitzerinnen und
waffenbesitzer das wäre der falsche weg
und deswegen muss zunächst das
bestehende recht vernünftig angewendet
werden während in berlin also weiter
diskutiert wird setzten zahlreiche
bürger in merseburg ein zeichen über 300
kamen heute zur trauerfeier für eines
der opfer von halle
bei mir ist jetzt matthias fornoff denn
auch das zdf- politbarometer hat sich
mit dem thema fremdenhass und
antisemitismus befasst guten abend
materien wie schätzen die befragten die
gesellschaftliche und politische
atmosphäre jetzt lande ein mit der
anschlag auf die synagoge in halle der
hat die wahrnehmung von antisemitismus
offenkundig verändert es gibt in
deutschland eine große oder sogar sehr
große judenfeindlichkeit das sagen jetzt
38 prozent der befragten
eine mehrheit von 55 prozent glaubt das
nicht im februar gingen nur 17 davon aus
das ist eine große judenfeindlichkeit
hier gibt dem vorwurf dass die afd durch
ihre positionen und aussagen mit
schuldig sei an rechtsextremen
gewalttaten stimmen 72 prozent zu große
mehrheiten der anhänger aller parteien
aber nur fünf prozent der afg anhänger
stimmen der these zu
hat sich denn im zuspruch für die
einzelnen parteien etwas geld ja es gibt
tatsächlich einiges an bewegung auch
weil andere themen oben stehen als vor
drei wochen beim letzten politbarometer
das war kurz nach dem klima paket der
bundesregierung
wenn am sonntag bundestagswahl wäre
kämen die union auf 29 prozent plus 2
die spd auf 14 prozent plus 1 die fdp 13
minus 1 fdp 6 und verändert linke 8 plus
1 und die grünen 24 3 das einzige
realistische bündnis mit klarer mehrheit
bliebe damit schwarz grün
vielen dank matthias fornoff für diese
informationen das ganze politbarometer
können sie wie immer im heute journal
sehen
um 22 uhr der bayerische
ministerpräsident und csu-chef söder
kann eigentlich zufrieden sein er hat
seinen traumjob wie er beteuert gilt als
potenzieller kanzlerkandidat und seine
umfragewerte steigen die seiner partei
allerdings nicht das will söder ändern
unter anderem mit einer ausweitung der
frauenquote nicht alle finden das so
toll trotzdem wurde söder beim parteitag
heute mit über 91 prozent wiedergewählt
aus münchen patricia schäfer es ist
unübersehbar die csu setzt auf
erneuerung jünger weiblicher digitaler
will markus söder seine partei machen er
weiß dass das nicht allen gefällt beim
parteitag in der münchner olympiahalle
wird söder für seinen kurs einfach nur
weiter zu machen wie bisher
es reicht auch nicht nur
reiche alte zeiten zu beschwören es
reicht nicht liebe freunde immer die
gleichen alten antworten auf neue fragen
zu finden
die delegierten quittierten die rede des
parteichefs nur mit mäßigem applaus war
sie welten markus söder mit gut 91
prozent wieder
und doch hat er nicht alle überzeugt der
frauenquote
es ist für mich unmöglich weil die
fragen die wir haben sehr viele
engagierte fragen und lief aus werden
wollen das sind immer noch was geworden
war jetzt schnell gekommen aber durchaus
durchdacht mehr frauen auf allen ebenen
not eine quote auch für junge das sind
kernpunkte einer parteireform die morgen
geschlossen werden soll
von der frauenquote bis zur online
mitgliedschaft auch außerhalb bayerns
viele veränderungen mit hohem tempo
manchmal standpunkte über den haufen die
wir jahrzehntelang vertreten und auch
verteidigt haben und ich glaube das ist
wichtig einfach den menschen zuzuhören
was sie wünschen
zum zuhören hat markus söder morgen viel
zeit insgesamt wieder gestärkt in die
nächste etappe barcelona ist
millionenmetropole und touristenmagnet
doch derzeit haben es alle schwer die
sich dort umschauen oder einfach nur den
alltag bewältigen wollen massenproteste
legen die stadt lahm seit am montag
anführer der katalanischen
separatistenbewegung verurteilt worden
besonders nachts kommt es zu heftigen
straßenschlachten mit der polizei
und heute generalstreik verbunden mit
einem riesigen verkehrschaos christel
hast es sind zehntausende und sie waren
drei tage lang unterwegs jetzt haben sie
ihr ziel erreicht barcelona was sie
hierher zieht ist die empörung über die
verurteilung von neuen
separatistenführer es gibt politische
gefangene in europa das ist
unverzeihlich da müssen wir auf die
straße gehen wir fordern unsere rechte
ein und vor allem die unabhängigkeit wir
fordern demokratie
sie protestieren friedlich vor dem
polizeihauptquartier aber fliegen eier
und andere nahrungsmittel auf die
sicherheitskräfte
nicht jeder hier verurteilt die gewalt
der letzten tage wenn die polizei uns
provoziert dann müssen wir darauf noch
antworten wir haben das recht zu
demonstrieren
seit vier nächten gibt es krawalle in
katalonien der spanische premier wird
deutlich niemand sollte glauben dass der
vandalismus und die gewalt die in
katalonien um sich greifen straffrei
bleiben werden der katalanische
regionalpräsident hatte die gewalt zwar
auch verurteilt aber gleichzeitig öl ins
feuer gegossen erfordert ein neues
referendum
selbst wenn wir für ein
unabhängigkeitsreferendum zu 100 jahren
verurteilt werden
wir müssen wieder über die
unabhängigkeit abstimmen
vor knapp einer stunde wieder barrikaden
die polizei entschlossen randale zu
verhindern
es wird wohl auch heute eine unruhige
nacht in barcelona damit sind wir bei
dir norbert ja genau die deutschen
bahnrad fahrerinnen sind schon
ordentlich auf touren gekommen nach
platz zwei im zweier team sprint muss
sich auch das deutsche quartett im
verfolgungsrennen nur einem konkurrenz
vierer geschlagen geben
großbritannien gewinnt den em-titel in
appeldoorn in den niederlanden links auf
dem podium scheinen die deutschen
radsportlerinnen schon ihren stammplatz
eingerichtet zu haben
franziska brause lisa brennauer lisa
klein und gudrun stock fahren im finale
zwar ein prima rennen doch gegen das
favorisierte quartett aus großbritannien
sind die deutschen damen chancenlos
die olympiasiegerinnen gewinnen mit
einem deutlichen vorsprung von knapp
drei sekunden den
europameisterschaftstitel mit platz zwei
aber sammelt das deutsche team auch noch
wichtige punkte für die
olympia-qualifikation und marschiert mit
holländischen klumpen als präsent zurück
in die kabine und dürfte für neue
erfolgreiche taten motiviert sein
polonaise auf blankem eis
die straubing tigers sind in feierlaune
denn gegen red bull nun mit münchen
gewinnt gelingt im bayerischen derby 1 5
zu 1 erfolg für den tabellenführer aus
der landeshauptstadt die erste
niederlage im zwölften saison spielen
ein echtes gabi füllt die hallen so auch
in straubing wo die gastgeber
überraschend gegen die seit elf spielen
ungeschlagenen münchner durch mal und in
führung gehen
nach 23 minuten nimmt das unerwartete
mit dem 2 0 für den außenseiter durch
brunnhuber genauere konturen an
und auch noch im zweiten drittel gar das
3 0 durch jerat der erste treffer für
den tabellenführer durch pasta zu beginn
des letzten drittels kommt spät genauer
zu spät zumal la granja und schließlich
eriksson die straubing tigers zu einem
in dieser höhe nie erwarteten 5 zu 1
sieg über münchen schießen mit diesem
erfolg gelingt es straubing in der
tabelle zumindest ein bisschen näher an
den bisher dominanten ehc münchen heran
zu rutschen
inzwischen sind ja einer kabine zum
schluss zeigen wir ihnen noch die arbeit
von zwei ganz besonderen handwerkerinnen
die us astronautin kristina cook und
jessica meyer sind die ersten frauen die
einen außeneinsatz im all als rein
weibliches team durchführen warum nicht
schon früher mag sich da einer fragen
ganz einfach sagt die nasa bislang waren
an bord nie ausreichend raumanzüge in
der benötigten frauen größe griffbereit
das wetter bleibt im süd osten sonnig
und trocken sonst muss man immer wieder
mit regen rechnen die details hat gleich
gunther tiersch um 22 uhr im heute
sondern freut sich christian sie was auf
sie wir danken für ihr interesse
wünschen ihnen noch ein schönes
wochenende und bis morgen denn sie
würden auch wieder sitz
[Musik]
unterm liebe zuschauer morgen wird es
auch nochmal nass bei uns heftige
gewitter haben uns heute überquert aus
dem südwesten sind sie aufgezogen hier
liegt diese städte die deutschland den
nächsten stunden verletzt aber da kommt
neuer regen allerdings in ziemlich
milder luft hier im süden werden das
über dem atlantik deutlich kälter wird
bis zur iberischen halbinsel und da
regnet es morgen auch ziemlich stark ja
bei uns letzten heftigen schauer die
noch den nordosten überqueren in den
nächsten stunden danach wird es trocken
in der zweiten nachthälfte fängt es
erneut an zu regnen und dieses
regengebiet zieht dann weiter nach
nordosten thüringens betroffen sachsen
brandenburg im norden kann die sonne
rauskommt dass es erst mal trocken und
auch hier im südlich der donau vor allen
dingen das bleibt auch am nachmittag so
werden sonst der regen hier im westen
aus schleswig holstein erreicht mit
diesem kräftigen südwind den wir noch
haben und der regen hier im osten auch
vorpommern in der zweiten tageshälfte
oder vereinigung späten nachmittag
beginnt es dann auch im schwarzwald
stärker zu regnen temperaturen dazu
meist zwischen 12 und 17 grad nur im
süden südlich der donau bis zu 20 grad
und wir behalten diese wärme es wird
noch wärmer am sonntag im süden und im
osten auch sonne ist dabei aber hier im
nordwesten und westen und es kräftig
regnen ich wünsche ihnen einen schönen
abend und machen sie es gut